these Japanese mechanics otherwise known
as snow monkeys are frolicking in the
waters of this primate sanctuary in
Texas so what are Pickford snow monkeys
the only primates other than humans that
can survive extreme cold doing here in
Texas
well a small group of these playful
creatures once angered the merchants of
kyoto japan by raiding their stores they
needed to be relocated or they'd be
killed the only place that would take
them was a remote corner of good old
Texas and this sanctuary was built for
them there so now instead of warming up
and hot volcanic Japanese Springs these
snow monkeys and their offspring use
water to cool off and have fun
something macaque seem to know how to do
wherever they are next time you get all
wrapped up and how serious the world is
think of these monkeys then go jump in a
lake